c'est
taille 1 mètre 69 x 62 kg son parcours
professionnel comprend 14 victoires et
une seule défaite
le représentant du club d'agde facteur
de maratka la russie timour valiev
[Musique]
j'aime cette journée j'apprécie le
moment tout le travail difficile a déjà
été fait j'entre sur l'octogone et je
fais tout ce que je peux
[Musique]
on
aujourd'hui j'ai déjà mangé une deux
trois quatre
c'est la cinquième fois que je mange
mais demain je serai léger
un bon petit déjeuner un bon déjeuner et
un peu de beurre de cacahuète avant le
combat
y en a marre
dimanche
magomed dis nous je suis stressé avant
tout premier combat
honnêtement non j'ai un peu le trac mais
je ne suis pas stressé
qui tu es là tu te concentres et tim au
valium comment sa ged et toi toi même
je suis déjà concentré
gc
argent
nous sommes en direct du stade ali alief
c'est le gfc dagestan
ne pensais pas qu'il est tout petit il
est très dangereux je pense qu'il tient
deux pistolets derrière son dos tu as
des pistolets n'est ce pas
l'important c'est de ne pas faire de
burnout le jour du combat donc nous
faisons des blagues nous discutons nous
rappelons divers histoire nous rigolons
beaucoup de gens des proches viennent
nous soutenir on peut voir tout le monde
a cumulé de l'énergie pour le combat
timour tu vas être le soigneur de ton
frère oui je vais faire ça quel
principal conseil lui donnerais tu
fais ce que tu sais faire c'est tout
[Musique]
au
daghestan chaque mohammad un surnom on
appelle les uns par leur nom de famille
d'autres par leur surnoms donald c'est
le surnom qu'il a reçus à 9 ans quand
nous avons fait connaissance au cours de
yushu sanda c'était un gars plein
d'énergie très intelligent il a gagné
beaucoup de tournois amateurs il est
champion du monde de ju jitsu est le
plus jeune champion amateur russe de mma
le premier combat professionnel très
important mais j'ai confiance en lui
parce que je connais son niveau il
s'entraîne toujours avec moi et beaucoup
de nos gars un jour on le verra parmi
les grands
le
[Musique]
si l'adversaire refusant de continuer le
combat à la fin du premier round 6 par
ko technique
le gagnant est magomed taille des gosses
russie maratka l'art
[Musique]
ils sont comment
d'humeur combative de quel autre humeur
je pourrais être
il ne me reste qu'à rentrer sur
l'octogone et montrer de quoi je suis
capable
[Musique]
l'invincible omar nouma données d'offre
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
message à tous
je pense que le daghestan à sa
réputation nous avons beaucoup de cas
nous avons notre champion quand j'étais
plus jeune je suivais ses combattants
rouste à mme rabin chami elsa aux rough
saadullah f
beaucoup de gars de mon école qui
appartenait à une autre génération
l'essentiel c'est de travailler dur ça
donne des résultats travailler dur être
discipliné et à y rêver dieu vous
donnera tout il suffit de faire quelque
chose de faire ce que vous voulez
[Musique]
l'oncle magomed et mon soigneur pour la
première fois parce que mon entraîneur
principal monceau ou kkf ne peut pas
être à mes côtés aujourd'hui
l'oncle magomed peut vous échauffer même
sans échauffement
vous ne faites rien il fait tout à votre
place il connaît certains points du
corps parce qu'il a une énorme
expérience en karaté
après ça on est plein d'énergie
[Musique]
il est important de ne pas décevoir son
équipe sa famille ses amis tout le monde
est venu me voir me soutenir ça met une
certaine pression émotionnelle mais il
faut monter sur l'octogone est donné le
meilleur de ce que j'ai aimé ce job
[Musique]
regardez saviola vlad
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis content du résultat du combat ne
va pas toujours comme prévu mais
l'essentiel est que j'ai gagné ici
et maintenant je sens que je vais tenter
ma chance dans la meilleure ligue du
monde
je pense que je le mérite in celle là je
pourrai le faire bientôt
signer avec moi les gars je viens de
rectifier un gars ayant eu 22 combats de
première ronde vous devriez signé avec
moi
[Musique]